why you
L and you
change and you try to make full out
[Music]
sh
so Thanos is the creation of Marvel and
DC writer and artist Jim Starin and
while Thanos is considered to be his
most popular creation I think it's also
important to note here that Jim Starin
was also well known for revamping the
characters Captain Marvel and Adam
Warlock who had previously been created
by Stan Lee Roy Thomas Jack Kirby in in
addition to either creating directly or
assisting in creating draxx the
destroyer and gamor and in 2003 during
an interview with Daniel best who at the
time and I believe continues to be the
owner and manager of uh Adeline Comics a
southern Australian um uh comic book
store he stated that his inspiration for
Thanos uh kind of came to him during a
psychology course in college while he
was in the Navy in addition to trying to
get work and comic books now he really
kind of attributes Thanos to sort of
anger management but he doesn't really
go into much more detail than that what
we do learn though is that he approaches
Marvel and Roy Thomas offers him an
opportunity to write a an issue of Iron
Man due to the fact that Marvel is
looking to rapidly expand their ranks in
terms of artists writers and
contributors to Marvel Comics we see
this ultimately playing out in the first
appearance of Thanos and Iron Man issue
number 55 and this is also our first in
introduction to the character draxx the
[Music]
Destroyer so Iron Man issue number 55 is
a interestingly done comic and in fact
it's actually done quite well
considering that it's Jim starling's uh
first run in Marvel Comics the comic is
written in such a way that it is both
open-ended and self-contained and I know
it seems like a contradiction to say
that but what I mean is that we see that
Thanos and draon Destroy are introduced
but we also see that the comic is kind
of left open-ended to where it's
entirely possible they could return but
if they weren't well received by comic
book fans then Marvel could have simply
just never brought them back and it
would not have changed the continuity of
the Iron Man Comics or the Avengers and
so in that sense it's really just a
chance for Jim Starin to demonstrate his
abilities to write a good story and to
uh create new characters characters in a
way that could Intrigue Marvel comic
fans and to see whether or not these
characters were done well enough that
people would want to see them return so
the comic opens up with draxx the
Destroyer warning Iron Man of an
impending threat called The Blood
Brothers but we see that Iron Man is
already engaged in combat with these two
villains iron man is overpowered and is
taken to a fortress somewhere on Earth
and then we kind of switch to the
perspective of Drax to destroyer and
Drax to Destroyer takes us on a journey
of source where he gives us a very
limited backstory to both himself and
Thanos and the reason why I say this is
limited is because we will see due to
the popularity of both of these
characters that in subsequent Comics
their backstories will be expanded on
quite a bit and we'll learn quite a lot
about both of these individuals although
in this video we're going to be focusing
mainly on Thanos we see that Thanos
along with his brother Eros are the
children of a being named Mentor and
Mentor is the deao ruler basically of
the Moon Titan one of the moons orbiting
Saturn and they live as a very very
peaceful race it is a very Lush
environment a very Lush a lush culture
that is housed below the surface within
a computer or a massive machine called
Isaac and as he's described to us Isaac
is just as much of a servant as a mentor
to the people of Titan now we see that
Thanos is exiled from the the moon Titan
due to the fact that he had attempted to
usurp father's Power by bringing
Weaponry to a planet that had none now
the goal of his father in uh exiling
Thanos was to help him come to terms
with the peaceful nature of their race
but we see the exact opposite happens
and in turn Thanos returns to Titan in
the intention of destroying not only his
entire civilization but being the last
being left and then to bestow himself or
to establish himself as the ruler of the
planet or of the Moon Titan we see that
in the conflict Mentor enlist the aid of
Kronos and if you recall our discussion
about Cosmic entities we talked about
how Kronos is one of the cosmic entities
and we see that Kronos is the one
responsible for the creation of Drax the
Destroyer now we see that draa Destroyer
is designed for the purpose of tracking
down and destroying Thanos and this is a
very important aspect of Drax the
Destroyer because this is a part of his
character that will never change his
inherent ability or his base power is to
always know where Thanos is at and
depending on the circumstances to have
enough power to it the very least
challenge him or to hold him off if not
destroy him entirely now we see that
Thanos and Drax to Destroyer engage in
combat and the planet on which they're
fighting is basically destroyed and Drax
the Destroyer is weakened and his
weakened State he is taken by Thanos
back to his base on Earth and is held
prisoner now we eventually catch up with
the current set of events that are
taking place on Earth and we see that uh
Tony Stark is being taken to I don't
know some kind of
location within this compound on the
planet Earth and we see that draon
Destroyer is attempting to communicate
with Tony Stark to tell him where he is
imprisoned at we see that Tony Stark
overpowers the blood brothers and fleas
to help Drax to Destroyer Escape but in
the attempt he is encounter encounters
Thanos now this is the first main
fullbody appearance that we see Thanos
in comic books and it's very important
that you guys kind of keep this in the
back of your heads so the reason why is
because Thanos is very very small
relatively speaking to how we recall him
in the Marvel Comics and the basis for
this is because this is how Jim Starin
initially envisioned Thanos as a person
whose physical stature was on par with
Tony Stark and Thor and those guys but
when the comic was released Roy Thomas
advised Jim Starling to beef the
character up that if Thanos was going to
be as formidable of a villain as Jim
Starin had intended him to be then he
needed to be larger than life and so
over the publication history of Marvel
Comics we will see the Thanos will
become quite a large individual in terms
of his physical stature we see that uh
Tony Stark along with draxx the
Destroyer are freed with the aid of
mentor and they take on Thanos but then
we learn that Thanos as he appears is
actually a robot we see that the base is
set for self-destruction and uh Tony
Stark and draa Destroyer Escape before
being killed we see them kind of shake
hands and come to the understanding that
it's entirely possible Thanos could
return but he may not and then they part
their separate ways now this brings an
end to Iron Man issue number
so Thanos reappears in Captain Marvel
issues number 26 through 33 I think and
for the remainder of this video in order
to save time we're going to do a summary
of sorts over these particular story
lines where he appears just because they
are very very in depth and even just a
discussion alone on one of these videos
could run us about 15 or 20 minutes so
we're not going to do a huge hour and a
half long discussion over the course of
these issues in Captain Marvel we learn
a couple things
one of the first things we learn is that
Thanos himself has actually now appeared
on the planet Earth where in Iron Man
issue number 55 it was simply just a
robot we also learned that Thanos is far
stronger than his robot counterpart that
appeared in Iron Man and we also learned
that Thanos is on the planet Earth in
Pursuit Of The Cosmic Cube we also see
that Thanos is being accompanied by
someone who is cloaked and never talks
now this person is very important and
over the the course of these issues we
learn that this person is mistress death
and that Thanos is in fact in love with
mistress death and simply wants to gain
her affections now this is extremely
important when it comes to the life of
Thanos and the reason why is because
virtually every campaign that Thanos
goes on The Infinity Gauntlet his
pursuit of the heart of the universe
these are all done in order to gain the
affections of mistress death and as the
Avatar of mistress death as he will be
bestowed in The Infinity Gauntlet story
line we see that he is basically the
representation of death and so his goal
is to eradicate all life now we don't
necessarily see that playing out until
The Infinity Gauntlet story line but
during the Captain Marvel Comics his
Pursuit Of The Cosmic Cube is twofold
the first part is to simply just gain
power he has a lust for power and
omnipotence the second is to give the
give the planet Earth as a gift to the
mistress death meaning that he is simply
going to eliminate all life on planet
Earth and then you know contribute that
as a gift to mistress death herself we
see that he launches a campaign against
Captain Marvel called the cre Crusher I
think and is called this because Captain
Marvel is himself a cre and we see that
Captain Marvel is engaged in combat with
a multitude of superheroes Ron and the
accuser I'm sorry villains and
superheroes Ron and the accuser nameer
the submarine
and he swiftly defeats almost all of
them but we see him allying himself with
the thing of the Fantastic Four and
confronting Thanos now Captain Marvel is
forcefully returned to his alra ego Rick
Jones and the thing is swiftly defeated
by swiftly I mean he's defeated with a
Simple Touch of Thanos um we also see
that with the assistance of uh The
Avengers Captain Marvel is able to
confront Thanos once Thanos has defeated
defeated Drax the Destroyer a second
time and gain the Cosmic Cube now once
he gains The Cosmic Cube he really kind
of becomes power drunk and He makes
himself one with the universe after
having defeated the uh Cosmic entity
Kronos we see that due to a series of
circumstances and over a course of a set
of events Captain Marvel challenges
Thanos to confront him without using his
Godlike powers and the reason he does
this is because there is a point in the
comics in the cosmic Cube storyline over
these issues in Captain Marvel where the
Cosmic Cube is lost Captain Marvel finds
the Cosmic Cube but Thanos had drained
the powers of the Cosmic Cube and imbued
himself with those Powers which is what
allowed him to become one with the
universe by challenging Thanos to
confront him without his Godlike Powers
Thanos is forced to rechannel these
energies back into the Cosmic Cube at
this point Captain Marvel destroys the
Cosmic Cube and Thanos is left without
these powers
[Music]
so Thanos reappears in warlock issue
number two and in order to understand
this portion of the video I would
suggest that if you haven't already go
back and watch our discussion about Adam
Warlock in addition to our discussion
about alternate realities because those
two things are very important in order
to understand this part of the video but
as we see warlock is engaged in combat
or at the very least is met with with
the Magus and Thanos appears and Thanos
in addition to Adam Warlock are able to
thwart the efforts of the maggus but
it's very interesting in terms of how
this happens there is a point whereby uh
when Thanos appears he and warlock in
addition to Gamora and pip the troll
escape and when they escape Adam Warlock
you know confronts Thanos and asks him
why it is that he is helping him you it
really just can't be out of the goodness
of his heart and Thanos states that he
is in pursuit of of the soul gy that uh
Adam Warlock possesses uh in order for
him to acquire this Soul Gym Adam
Warlock has to succeed and he also takes
Adam Warlock to a time machine called
knowledge one and what we learn is that
Adam Warlock travels into the future and
is able
to stop this Rift so to speak is able to
nip the point in the bud by which he
becomes the Magus and by doing so the
maggus ceases to exist as he's engaging
in combat with Thanos Thanos is
ultimately successful along with Adam
Warlock and it's believed that Thanos is
able to absorb the energies of the Soul
gim that the maggus possessed and as a
result it is one step closer towards The
Infinity
[Music]
Gauntlet so after the events of warlock
issue number two in addition to a couple
other smaller story lines that had taken
place Thanos had presumably been killed
and he had disappeared appeared from
Marvel Comics entirely for almost 25
years and in 1990 with the Thanos Quest
issue number one we see Thanos return to
Marvel Comics and it is done in
spectacular fashion we see that the
cosmic entity death had sensed an
imbalance in the universe something was
a miss and it's presumed that this was
because Thanos despite the fact that he
was destructive had more or less kind of
become a necessity in the universe much
like galatis and the uh uh cel
with regards to their relationship in
the universe Thanos was the embodiment
of what it meant to destroy what it
meant to be death and so death had
revived him had brought him back to life
and had tasked him with the open-ended
assignment of fixing this imbalance what
the imbalance was wasn't specified to
Thanos and so in this instance he's
really kind of a guy trying to do the
best that he can although he does it in
a pretty terrible way we also see that
draxx the Destroyer who had previous
previously been killed was revived by
Master order in Lord Chaos and was
tasked with the assignment of locating
and destroying Thanos the thano quest
Comics both issues one and two take us
on a journey as Thanos comes across some
of the most powerful characters in the
Marvel Comics the Elders of the universe
the champion and he is able to defeat
them and attain their infinity gems and
with The Infinity Gauntlet story line we
see this coming to fruition and we see
just what happens when Thanos is able to
acquire The Infinity Gauntlet and able
to use it for his own
[Music]
purposes so The Infinity Gauntlet is
considered by many to be the crowning
achievement of Jim Stalin's work at
Marvel Comics and I would go as far as
to say that it's probably one of the
greatest stories ever told and in The
Infinity Gauntlet we see some great
characters returning we see uh the
Silver Surfer returning which was very
exciting for a lot of people because as
one of the original villains so to speak
of the Fantastic 4 who of course had
turned into a good guy by the end of the
issue or the end of the series uh we had
seen that the silver surver had
disappeared from Marvel Comics for quite
some time and so to see him return was
welcomed by a lot of people we saw Adam
Warlock return to the scene and Adam
Warlock at the end of the Warlock
storylines the Warlock Comics had been
confined to the soul gy and Marvel had
kind of set it up with Adam warlock's
character in a very interesting way Adam
Warlock would only really return under
circumstances that were absolutely dire
and The Infinity Gauntlet was one of
those circumstances as we see with the
story as the comic opens up we see that
Thanos is a longside Mesto and Mesto is
kind of the Satan version of uh or I
guess a version of Satan in Marvel
Comics and we see that Thanos has
captured The Infinity Gauntlet and has
been elevated to the level of
omnipotence uh we don't really see
exactly what all he's capable of but we
see towards the end of the comic that he
is virtually unchallenged by anybody in
the uh in the Marvel Comics that is
confined to our 616 Universe we see that
uh the Silver Surfer arrives to warn
Doctor Strange of the impending threat
that Thanos has returned and has gained
The Infinity Gauntlet we also see that
the Silver Surfer in a flashback
alongside Drax the Destroyer had met
with Adam Warlock in the soim and had
warned Adam Warlock of what was
happening and enlisted his Aid and of
course we see Adam Warlock along with
gamor and pip the troll coming back to
our reality in order to assist in
stopping uh Thanos we see that Thanos in
an effort to use his power to
demonstrate his love for mistress death
um begins making a series of events take
place of course he creates this kind of
um I wouldn't go as far as to say tomb
uh but I would say Shrine would be the
best description he creates the shrine
for Madam death in the middle of space
uh but again she seems unsatisfied and
distant with what he's done so far we
see that nebula who had previously been
killed by Thanos has been returned to
life albe it in a zombified and decrepit
state in a shadow of her former self uh
we also see that Thanos wipes out half
the life in the sentient universe or I'm
sorry half the sentient life in the
universe with a snap of his fingers and
this is where the story line gets very
intriguing and ultimately we see that by
Thanos destroying half the life in the
universe that a large percentage of some
of our favorite Earthbound characters
are gone and so almost all the X-Men are
gone almost all the Avengers are gone
and so really we see that Adam Warlock
along with uh Silver Surfer and Doctor
Strange were able to assemble this kind
of ragtag group of villains and
superheroes from the planet Earth along
with other individuals from across the G
I'm sorry Across the Universe and in
order to try to stop Thanos and bring it
into his schemes we also see that Adam
Warlock has assembled an army of cosmic
entities galatis uh Master order Lord
Chaos eternity and they have all come
together for the efforts of stopping
Thanos although we do not see eternity
until much later on as the story
continues we see that Thanos basically
uh uses his abilities to stop uh
everyone that opposes him with the
utmost of ease we see that um the
Incredible Hulk is virtually powerless
against him we see that draxx a
destroyer is powerless against him
there's really no one that can stand in
his way and once almost all of the
Earthbound Immortal forces from across
the universe are thwarted then we see
the cosmic entities step in and again
the cosmic entities just like everybody
else are thwarted just as easily until
Thanos comes toe-to-toe with uh eternity
and because Thanos is the equivalent of
Eternity albeit in a mortal form at this
point um he is basically on par and is
able to thwart eternity and take up his
role as uh the representation of all
eternity within our Earth 616 universe
and this is when we see the story line
come to an end or kind of wind down and
eventually disappear we see that as a
result of Thanos becoming one with the
universe he leaves his physical body in
a very vulnerable state at this point
virtually all forces that are opposed to
him have either been captured and held
in stasis as we see with the cosmic
entities or they have been uh eliminated
entirely or rematerialized or in some
way rendered incapable of uh challenging
him as we see with many of the
Earthbound forces and so what we
actually see is that of all people
nebula takes The Infinity Gauntlet off
of his arm and grants herself with the
power of the universe we see that Thanos
is reduced back to his normal State and
with Adam warlock's uh appeal to the
heroes to combat nebula we see that
nebula has now become the main villain
in The Infinity Gauntlet storyline
ultimately nebula is defeated and the
infinity gems are taken out of The
Infinity Gauntlet and at this point we
see Adam Warlock form a group called The
Infinity watch to which Thanos will be a
part
[Music]
of so thanos's abilities are quite
profound and quite powerful when you
look at him even before The Infinity
Gauntlet and especially after The
Infinity Gauntlet
Thanos is a member of a race called the
titanian eternals and while these
individuals are quite powerful Thanos
being a mutant among these peoples have
powers that exceed even their abilities
and so he is really kind of a man unto
himself in terms of what it is that he
can do in comparison to his own alien
race now when you compound this with the
fact that up until The Infinity Gauntlet
he had um empowered himself even further
by use of technological advancements and
various other modifications then he
became quite formidable and when he was
revived by death prior to The Infinity
Gauntlet he had his abilities enhanced
even further along the line in addition
to I believe being granted immortality
now from this point Thanos became uh
virtually unrivaled and of course with
the uh Infinity Gauntlet um he was
rivaled by nobody within our Earth 616
universe but even for the most strongest
of foes The Incredible Hulk for example
or the Juggernaut th Thanos is able to
overpower them although it may take some
effort on his part and more so than he
would normally have to exert against
other foes we also see that Thanos is
incredibly durable in terms of the
amount of damage that he can take in and
keep moving forward for example he
withstood a full blast of black Bolt's
voice and for those of you guys who are
unaware blackbolt is one of is the
leader of a group called The Inhumans it
actually becomes the leader of the the
alien race the cre and blackbolt with
his voice it's quite powerful depending
on how he chooses to project it if he
whispers he can annihilate a human being
an entire block of uh of a city if he
screams he can destroy planets or even
Stars so in order for him with with
Thanos being able to withstand virtually
the full brunt of uh of black Bolt's
voice within reason considering they
were on uh the planet Earth I believe u
that's quite profound when you look at
the amount of damage that he can
withstand but I would go as far as to
say that despite the physical abilities
that Thanos May possess his most
powerful and most beneficial attribute
is his intellect because he is a genius
in virtually everything even forms of
science that far exceed anything that
we're capable of on the planet Earth and
so while you have people like Reed
Richards and Peter Parker and Bruce
Banner who are the for foremost
authorities in their respective field
fields of science their knowledge is far
surpassed by Thanos and so in addition
to this he is a master strategist he is
able to predict the moves of people in
Conflict before they even choose to make
it and so he's always one step ahead
he's always planning and always scheming
in terms of his implementations of his
goals and his ideas in the Marvel
[Music]
Universe so the question becomes what
does Marvel have in store for Thanos
what does the Marvel Cinematic Universe
have in store for the villain Thanos
well to me there really seem to be some
obvious fingers being pointed to The
Infinity Gauntlet we see the infinity
gems already in existence and it would
really be disappointing if the Marvel
Cinematic Universe introduced the
concept of infinity gyms only to let us
know that Thanos is going to be in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but didn't
actually have have him capture The
Infinity Gauntlet I would be vastly
disappointed but there are some great
story lines with Thanos there's Marvel
the end whereby Thanos captures the
heart of the universe and by doing so
becomes one with the universe himself
but I don't really feel like that's a
storyline that the Marvel Cinematic
Universe would go with because you're
talking about a character who becomes so
omnipotent that he's actually beyond
anything he had when he was uh in
possession of The Infinity Gauntlet and
would virtually be unrivaled by anybody
because in Marvel the end Thanos wasn't
necessarily defeated he just simply saw
no point in maintaining his power and
gave it up on his own there was really
no one there to stop him he was kind of
coached Along by Adam Warlock but
nonetheless you know he gave it up by
himself no one was able to stop him he
simply just ended the Universe um you
know for me Thanos is really a character
who I think should be done in a way to
where his intellect is respected that
he's really not some kind of mind
numbering uh mind-numbing blundering
fool who's able to beat people up but
just mutters onliners and just throws
out stupid catchphrases here and there
you know a character who would be on par
with Abomination from The Incredible
Hulk it'd be wildly disappointing to see
that because Thanos is an incredibly
powerful villain and being so powerful
he has an intelligence to go along with
it and I think that Marvel has really
kind of put an emphasis on having more
well-rounded characters having
characters who aren't simply isolated to
one attribute of their personal ality
but to having as many attributes of
their personalities included in the
characters as they're written so that we
get a full understanding of them as a
whole and they're not simply written off
as caricatures with silly ideas I'm
really hoping that Thanos is continued
in this trend that Marvel is doing with
their characters in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and ultimately I think that
Thanos is going to be a great inclusion
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe of
course we know that he's going to be the
centerpiece so to speak and Guardians of
the Galaxy and we know that he is going
to have involvements further along the
line in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and so for me it's really kind of
interesting to see how this plays out
and it's really kind of interesting to
see how it is that Thanos is going to be
portrayed in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe with that being said I'm going
to go ahead and bring this video to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace now the way that the
Nova cor is set up is really kind of
intriguing in and of itself the Novae
consists of four Cate ories of people
with the highest category being one
individual the very base level of the
Nova cor are called corpsmen and these
are individuals who have just graduated
from the novacore training school or
training camp although we see of course
after the annihilation storyline when
the Nova cor is reformed there's no
traditional store no traditional uh
training camp per se they're just made
into members of the Nova